welcome to the show happy Wednesday
least I think it's Wednesday
let me see I've been drinking every day
so yes
Wednesday yeah that's my new system
anyway terrific show I love her Darcy
Cardin is on the program tonight we will
be having a chat with her first let's
see what the writers have to say about
what's been going on on the news right
yeah man what's going on here hey did
you hear this the National Spelling Bee
has been canceled yeah so now the corona
virus is even affecting kids who never
left the house because they're nerds you
get it hey check this out in New York
public health officials are recommending
that New Yorkers masturbate more yeah
yeah officials said just close your eyes
and pretend you're on the D train
I'm waiting yes that's exactly what kind
of laugh that would have gotten hey
according to a new study having
testicles is what makes men more
vulnerable to the coronavirus yeah in
other words I'm safe and I'm the guy
that got zinged that's the beauty of it
all right that monologue a little on the
dirty side